where did you find that she's very picky
how much cheaper it's probably about 15
people in the room the finances right
that's great
you know powerful why she's gonna be on
a soup kitchen
[Music]
so I just I just want to thank you guys
you know you are the shining stars the
examples of what can be possible
everybody here has been home witness
Wednesday which is what kind of brings
us together if it goes well and
everybody enjoys the food and the
network and the company and the vibe
we're going to be doing we're gonna be
doing this bit more regulate well we'll
just invite invite anyone that's been on
Windows Wednesday to come and have
dinner and really there's no strong
agenda it's just have fun to network to
get to know each other and I don't have
one AB in situation whereby cuz we've
got so many people coming on Windows
Wednesday but I'll bump into someone in
the street who's been on Windows
Wednesday and I'll forget them I don't
want that to ever happen so I want to be
on a first-name basis and really
familiar everybody so if ever there's
anything you need from me with us
tonight or anytime we're here I'm
personally and also it also as a company
we're going to be after the after the
main course is we won't be giving the
opportunity of people to just share a
few words of success and say what
they've been up to and what's going on
and we can we can celebrate that and and
then I think there's some music coming
on a bit later and you can just stay
here until you're either drunk
[Music]
I'm strong
[Music]
[Music]
the best things in life I wish to know
what every second and I ain't not be
rich enough
and you know what
did everybody enjoy the down awesome I
just awesome I just want to say firstly
a massive thank you to Amelia Asante
because if it wasn't for Amelia the
dinner wouldn't have happened she's
organized it
she's contact with you all as I was
going around chatting to everybody and I
think I've managed to speak to just
about everybody even if only briefly
tonight one of the things that I just
find amazing is a lot of you are here
because of some of the other people in
the room so like for instance I know
Becky and John said if it wasn't for
James Armstrong we wouldn't be here
where is James James still here there he
is he's still here James Armstrong but a
lot of people said that you know about
James and then other people see it
wasn't for Alastair and the crazy thing
is I mean Emanuel was like if it wasn't
for Rahim I wouldn't be here and now
that's not having dinner you know which
is just incredible and I think it goes
to show as well some of the more recent
winners Wednesday's so you said you
wouldn't have been in if it wasn't for
James in six months time at the next
dinner
guaranteed there'll be someone saying if
it wasn't from Becky and John we
wouldn't be here and I think the power
of just sharing your stories the power
of you know being being light to the
world and sharing success is absolutely
fantastic I mean the amount of people
have said to me if it wasn't for NSA I
wouldn't have been on the Academy now
I'm financially free if it were and if
it wasn't for Lear and Sheryl then you
wouldn't have said it's just and did you
was that the case tell me what happened
yeah
and now you're here because of em say
and now someone's going to be here in
six months because of you and I think
that is that's the rippling effect that
it has so I'm really excited and I know
some of you guys as well I have been
doing such incredible things we've had a
new book that's being rich and making
property compliance easy this has been
written by Hannah Anthony and James as
well
a new book a new book so and we are we
published this my company's published
this so highly would suggest getting
this it is on Amazon but if you honestly
if you guys want to do I think this year
2020 this new decade okay
last year we made some money in property
some of you are making two grand a month
so you're making 1500 a month so you're
making 10 grand a month so you're making
15 grand a month but like I think this
year's gonna be a year we all want to
take things to a whole new level with
you guys we're going to be doing dinners
a bit more regularly cuz I think
tonight's been fun we're gonna be and
honestly and I really mean it when I say
it if if you my philosophies always you
make a move on mekin if you make a move
I'll make a move anything you need for
me personally anything you need from the
team you know we're completely here for
you we've got you back you want to write
a book so the people say tell me do you
mind if I write a book about property
because it is that competition with your
book I'm like you know what I tell you
my competition is my competition are the
banks and the universities and the media
telling people a different message which
is to get a job and and to work to you
67 that's who I'm fighting against I'm
not fighting against people spreading
the same message so delighted to see
some YouTube channel set up shout out to
a manual for your feet for your property
videos you've been doing shout out to
Deb's
anyone else Jess and Jess and Jordan
with your YouTube channel Raheem Callum
you know seeing you guys spread the
message makes me ridiculously excited so
again if you want to collab if you want
support with that I am cheering you on
and everything so I think 2020 is gonna
be amazing
now I don't know if we've got time for
everybody to say a few words
if anyone does that maybe we could just
go around if people just want to speak
for 30 seconds or a minute
and just just sort of share something
that they've done a really amazing and
all all that's going on I'd like to I'd
like to give an opportunity for people
to do that I was speaking with my wife
before I left today and that's remaining
I saw a picture of a nice to work in
McDonald's and at that point that's a
really low point in my life but everyone
here and pretty much not almost
everyone's story from YouTube open it
inspiration and honestly thank you Sarah
Moore for creating a platform for young
black guys like myself
in 2018 I went through a bit of a tough
time I lost my one but prophecy and
Samuel and everyone I see James Ricky
Alastair everyone is just been such an
amazing support network and it really
matter what slump I get into I know
these guys will pull me out of it so I
just want to say thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
I don't know if you know how much he
popped us out but from the first when
it's on a Wednesday video
we come to you with with our business
plan and search and you have just tear
up and make a new one and we got
progress on that and now 1/8 purchased
and another million-pound business and
things will go really really well
you are truly inspiring and you the
energy and the enthusiasm you've got
that has helped everybody here in fact
it was positively and billing expedite
our programs so I just be a pilot about
how my last year went so basically I
started with rent rent rent I say of now
diverted into my refurbishing refinance
and development as well as establish my
own estate agency where I manage that
himself we do everything a week already
Manitoba hundred properties as well
making about six better income a
dominant six because for me it's
inspiring to come here and see people
while you guys and you know several
people on the table that a crash course
and now you here we all April in this
room has has one master thing in common
we've all come from a [ __ ] place in our
life
everyone has we have we've all come from
a really bad place in life and we're now
here because as your show we didn't stop
like who is this totally easy it's been
hard yes we've had negative things about
reject you about people tell me you're
broke you can't do it good thing you
know worker but we're all here because
we did not stop yes there's not really
much else to cover I don't think
everyone's kind of touched every base
but from a personal experience I think I
want to thank the group of base but I
think everybody here today is I've spoke
to you that most of it at least I knew
at some point and the stories we all
spoke about on this noise we shared it
reinforces the confidence that what
we're doing is right at least it's not
as simple as just one plus one equals
two but very community work doesn't
manatee behind because I could look
around this table of friendly faces I
know our kind of conversation with you
guys feel comfortable like we can get on
you know I'm gonna share the same song
life cause before I do a different type
of property we've got different reasons
why we wanted people to help I we're all
here for the same reason and I really
really wanna thank you for creating a
community of people that think
differently about this world and a
positive why people in this room tonight
and everyone's got their own story it's
not a race it's not a who comes first
another competition is everyone's got
their own story everyone
their own journey of us doing what
they're going to do we've had to make up
eyes and we had some bloody political
lows and we're coming up being honest
coming up for some really all for lows
as well right now it hurts it really
hurts
and we're here because this group is
positive salmon leaders positive and
between us we've got a positive mindset
we're just trying to steer through the
[ __ ] right now to be honest we've got
two properties in South Hampton and well
I'd like to connect with anyone that's
down South Hampton way where we just
spawn very much that's it really took
more than that
we're down south we feel like our own
little bit because
the chat talk connect as we'd like to do
that but here's what is positive there
is light in the tunnel but everyone
Billy is just I am so happy to be here
I couldn't be anywhere else in the world
I'd rather be the right empty buzz right
now and a lot of people have said
there's a couple of themes that come up
a lot of people have said about
perseverance and persistence when the
going gets tough so what I want to
publicly say is it able is going through
a rough time or when the rough time
happens do not be alone like tell one
another tell me tell the team tell one
another because that's what we're for
would you leave your friends behind
listen if you are not getting people
jealous of you or dissing you or
whatever then you're not probably doing
enough I mean honestly like who's making
take mend or warm up fresh your hand
okay maybe like half the room
being in time per month but here's the
thing you're potent you pour this one
another on my ten-man amazing that is
not normal in Britain in Britain that's
very very weird accordion playing is
wage this year so you've got your whole
years right - already in my three weeks
and that's just incredible but in
Britain if you told your but the old
friends that you did that they're not
gonna be massive fans so it's fine Pizza
yeah exactly so you know I just think
this this year what I would say is what
if you knew you couldn't fail what would
you do and then just go do that
whether that's if you want to be an a
speaker if you want to be an engaged
development if you want to do something
just grow a buck
you know however crazy it is I think
this is the year this is the decade to
go do it and what I want to say is I
personally and together everyone here we
believe in we believe in you we believe
[Music]